for telling us about your research
interest as well
now i would like to invite our mentor
gibliano
to please introduce himself to the
fellows over to youtuber liana
good morning everybody my name is
japoliano
i'm originally from brazil and uh
currently i am in the
at the university of chicago pursuing
postdoctoral studies
working with neuroblastoma which is a
pediatric cancer
so i should just share my slides now
uh yes you can okay i have to make it
important for them
how many minutes do i have for this
presentation
maybe five to ten minutes so
not very long okay so i will go to the
core
of this so uh i already introduced
myself
i work with epigenetics and you can
understand that epigenetics
as modifications of the chromatin
structure that control
gene accessibility and expression
and there are these several levels of uh
control
in the basically in the genetic sequence
so you have the
uh cell and the nucleos and then there
are several regions
in the unidimensional sequence of the
dna that control
expression but basically we understand
that genetics have has modifications in
dna and histones that control
gene expression and uh particularly i
work with a
one particular dna modification
the covalent cytosine modification in
dna
that's called 5-hydroxymethylcytosine so
this modification here with a hydroxyl
group
in in the in the methyl regions
of the dna why we want to
use bioinformatics for epigenetics
because uh there are just
too many regions the human genome
sequence is just
very big so we need we really need
bioinformatic methods to access the
information
so i said that i work with neuroblastoma
which is a complex disease
that originates in the central nervous
system
particularly in the sympathetic kingly
and the adrenal medulla
[Music]
really the concept that i would like to
bring here is the idea that as a
research
research project involving in my case
neuroblastoma
allows an interdisciplinary real world
real world problem solving
in my case i particularly work with mds
biochemists
information statisticians chemists and
physicists
and so working with a project basically
allows you to have this contact with
just
many areas and many different uh
positions many different
areas of science and i think this is a
very important experience to have
i'll skip this a little bit but
basically neuroblastoma has two
different cell populations one is the
adrenergic which is basically a
cell population that is differentiated
whereas the other
population is called the mesenchymal
cell type which is
uh basically stem cells which are
non-differentiated
these differentiated cells the
adrenergic cells they are killed by
chemotherapy
the mesenchymal cells cannot be targeted
by chemotherapy
but they uh are enriched in disease
progression so they'll basically
basically
allow disease to become resistant to
chemotherapy
the key point is that mesocamo cells can
be differentiated into adrenergic cells
so my
the goal of my research is to identify
tumors that have ma uh
high levels of mesenchymal cells so that
we can differentiate
them and basically make them
therapeutically target
targetable by chemotherapy
so this is one method for achieving that
goal basically this is a
hierarchical clustering it's a machine a
machine learning method for
classifying the cells dividing the cells
between mesenchymal cells and adrenergic
cells
and we want to apply these methods in
one
technology called liquid biopsy which is
basically
isolating blood from the patient and
then
sequencing these epigenetic markers
because we think
that in this sample we can differentiate
the adrenergic and the mesenchymal
markers and then tell whether
the tumor that a patient carry is a more
mesenchymal or adrenergic tumor so i
think it's
really really important to be
resilient to start a bioinformatics
project bioinformatician is
bioinformatics is just like any other
task in this life
such as running a marathon nobody is
born with the capability to run this
long distance but we all have the
potential
so this is a food after food everyday
exercise
that requires discipline anyone can do
it
provided that they can they see
themselves enjoying the experience
or the reward that is associated with
the uh the project so in conclusion
basically we think that uh
bioinformatics and genomics have a great
potential to impact medicine
in neuroblastoma particularly this is
seen by the classification of these
mesenchymal and adrenergic cells
and i think that the future of
personalized medicine is constructed
through the involvement of young
scientists in
bioinformatics as i said step after step
and
one day at a time basically thank you so
much
i will take questions if you guys have
any questions for me
so actually i have a question uh why did
you
specifically get interested in this
project in europe yes
because i was interested in applying
machine learning
and artificial intelligence in genomics
because
as i said during my phd studies i
realized that there were
lots and lots of data that were
generated in the genomics field and
uh these uh bioinformatics is the few
that
the field that can leverage and use all
of the information that has been
generated in the past
few years in the genomic fields and
really
develop techniques or therapeutics or
products that can benefit
the human society in general and
neuroblastoma is really interesting
because it's a pediatric cancer
so it has a great potential to impact
positively the lives of children
basically
thank you does anyone else have any
questions
so i think they don't have but still
this uh if they come up with the
question they can ask in the chat
anytime
so i now i would want offer dial to
please introduce himself over to you
offer diet in miami
yes please thank you so much all right
good evening i'm of the americorps
um a media scientist
i'm a father i meant to put a mental
health scientist i'm from nigeria
with special interest in infectious
diseases
and bioinformatics so basically i joined
this project
to you know develop my
tools for research into infectious
diseases
thank you
thank you so much so uh we are uh
taking a note of for the interest of
everyone and
we would have our mentors guiding you
all about how you can start with your uh
research fellowship
before we do that i would want eddie
nuke to introduce himself please and
then we can
uh go ahead with the session over to you
okay thank you so much everyone
my name
i'm in is i'm here in the united states
as uh students
and i'm interested in uh researching
more into
computational biology and bioinformatics
especially in a way where we can i can
use that informative tool
to uh to do some public
health intervention and that's why i'm
joining this research fellowship to
learn more
thank you so much
hi so i am recently graduated from
uh san diego's college mumbai in india
i'm an incoming graduate student at data
institute of fundamental research where
i will be joining a developmental
neuroscience lab
so in that lab uh they have lab
techniques and various transcriptomics
techniques as
uh our mentor says that there's a lot of
chipset data that
we need to analyze and i'm an incoming
student master student over there
so via this research
fellowship or research fellowship i want
to learn the techniques which will help
me to
[Music]
improve my skills and work in the lab
are more efficient
thank you thank you so much pibas
it's really good to have you all here
today and
it was nice to hear to your research
interests as well
now i would like to pass it on to elia
so that he
uh he can talk more about the program
over the media
all right thank you sonalika and it was
great to see all of you i'm
gonna share my screen
so um because many of you are joining
here for the first time
i do want to give you a brief
introduction of what the program is
going to be structured like so that you
know what to expect
and also you know how to make the most
out of this program
so the program is divided into these
three stages
the first stage is an introduction many
of you come from different levels
of your skills and many different
kind of levels in terms of knowing what
kind of data you want to analyze what is
your project
and as you go through this stage
we're hoping that you can learn how to
use
big data so most of us know that
big data exists out there i think many
of us have
difficulties analyzing big data and
understanding something meaningful using
this big data and so for that purpose
we have some big data analysis tools and
through the coursework you'll get
a chance to get to know how to use them
uh
introductory coursework includes some
basic terminology
as well as project examples and i'll
talk about that in just a few minutes
and the project examples and the data
sets that we use
the benefit of using those is because
they come from
expert labs so they were generated in an
environment
that makes this good data and they also
come
with an explanation why it was generated
how it was generated what did they do to
analyze it
so really learning from experts is
following that same publication
then uh evaluation so we talk a lot
about
how important it is not to only come up
with
a research project but to also come up
with
a competitive research topic a topic
that is going to be interesting
to not only you but people in the field
so if you take
as an example um you know neuroscience
or
cancer or infectious diseases
there are so many different types of
projects that you could potentially do
and before you know where to focus your
energy and your time
it's really important to identify a
competitive research proposal
and that's where the mentorship
essentially starts
so the way that this works is you
complete some coursework
you get to a certain threshold after
which you are able to submit the
research proposal
and that research proposal gets
evaluated by our team
so then once you understand what is a
competitive
topic and a proposal that would be
interesting to
people that are going to be listening to
your project
you also need to think about what data
set
could be used to study this question and
also
have a sense of what kind of tools and
what kind of methods
you would need to be using and so the
objective of this proposal
is to really present and we'll hear
today a few presentations
present in a compelling way the reason
why this project is meaningful and
the fact that you know how to actually
uh
go about the analysis part as well so
in many cases you will know a part of
that
but you will not know everything and
that's why
the next stage is practicing and so
practicing
is really trying you might try many
different methods until you find a
method that works
and you might try several different data
sets until you find a data set that
answers the question and maybe has all
of the metadata that you need
maybe you will combine it with other
data sets so it's a really
iterative process and so that's where
we will try to guide you through some
practical
suggestions through these weekly
meetings
as well as help you structure the
process
using our weekly progress report and the
interaction on slack
so some of the important things that you
will get
to know in these research fellowship
meetings
we will discuss different types of data
sets we will talk about different
project examples and you will hear from
your peers
how they have gone about structuring
their project proposal
and i think that should give you a good
understanding of how you might apply
the same process to your own data you
will also be able to
leverage some of these publicly
available data sets and potentially
we hope that in this forum you might be
able to
share with each other some great data
sets that you have found
i'll give you an example and maybe in a
few minutes we can ask uh someone else
actually to talk about this
uh for covid there's so much data that
has been generated in the past year year
and a half
that uh you know it seems like you can
almost ask any question but in reality
a lot of the data sets lack important
and critical metadata about
the data how it was generated why it was
generated
where it was generated and when and so
having access to all of the metadata
is really critical to be able to ask
these interesting and important
questions
so finding that data set is not easy
and many of us study similar topics and
are interested in
similar topics so we would all benefit
from sharing those data sets with each
other and so we hope that
during the sessions not only will we
show you kind of some practical ways
that you can find data sets
but we will be putting out different
types of curated data sets
and finding projects that have some good
collections of data that you can find
now we will also go through some
examples
and so these examples are going to be
uh just one moment
[Music]
till elia is coming i just wanted to
know whether all the research fellows
have filled in the weekly report form or
not
if yes please tell me in the chat and if
not then please update your form
okay sorry about that yes and and please
do update that in the chat box
um and and finally what i want to
kind of get to is uh the fact that
um it's a process that helps
um all of us see your journey
right and so what we hope uh that we
will get out of this summer process
is a number of high quality
competitive projects that could be
shared
with a wider scientific community so
before i go into that i want to talk
about
you know how you can make your
experience in this research fellowship
the most effective for you and to
understand
what effective means i want to ask
all of you um if you could think for a
second
what is the objective
that you want to reach right what is the
goal of this research fellowship for you
for some of you it might be
you get disconnected or something like
that i guess
yes we cannot uh yeah
[Music]
okay so sonalika maybe you can ask oh
yeah
let's go ahead then uh so dhruv are you
ready with your presentation
i am giving you the answer sorry
i just have to interrupt you before uh
group session so i need to introduce
myself here
yes ma'am sure so uh yes ma'am dr
harpreet please introduce yourself she's
a program mentor and
also she looks after the research
fellowship program so yes
okay so hello everyone uh let me
share my slide first
um sorry guys i
i actually that's what the guy told me
and i
just somehow missed it he told me
they're gonna be uh turning off the
electricity
but here i am back um so sorry about
that
so um could i ask you um to share
what is the reason that you are joining
this fellowship and what is your
objective what do you
want to get out of this and maybe we can
start with some of the newer people that
introduce themselves today
so yes maria can you please let us know
why you are
what objective you are looking for
[Music]
um yes so um i basically want to improve
some technical skills that to
like work in bioinformatics field in
the future and also to do a master's and
i think it's important to learn some
basic skills
and also to um probably make an
a research project that could be useful
in
my country or latin america and
that could probably turn out into a
paper probably in the future
okay thank you and what about you
caption
uh well yeah same i i wanna i'm just
relatively new to bioinformatics
so right now we just want to learn the
tools necessary
and for the research i'm thinking
something around agriculture
because i'm interested about climate
change and
we're going to need to use um
bio biotech in agriculture
to for the crops and stuff so
yeah i'm still interested in that
and what about you hamza
or maybe eddie okay can tell us
his objective is not here
so any one of you can and yes yes please
thank you
um i want to uh use
i want to learn how to use a
computational biology
back to uh how to use a bioinformatics
tool like i've said earlier
to you know do some public health
intervention
as a phd student
okay that's nice and
who else wants to tell us about their
objective or shall i
call out names only then you would be
sharing
why don't you tell us
all right i'm mainly looking for
some skill development uh you know
learning some skills in
machine learning and r programming
python
also i'm trying to get some information
in trying to
apply those skills to transcriptomics
data visualization
and you know the best way to do it is
as a part of a research project and so
i'm
currently in the middle of going through
courses and i'll try to finalize
my you know my interest of my project
address soon
machine learning reminds me that we have
the program ongoing the machine learning
for biomedical drug discovery one
so children are you taking part in that
as well
so yes yeah i did i didn't
attend uh today's session i
actually need to go through the first
session previously
and i i will be getting in touch with
you regarding you know access to the
lectures and everything yes yes so all
the research fellows would have the
access to the program page and
yes you you can have the videos from the
program page directly then
i'll add you there thank you chairman so
much
yes yeah uh over to you yeah
i see that ali uh wanted to also share
ali do you want to share why you joined
or what's your objective
yes uh i'm i'm
i'm now learning the uh whole genome
sequencing by
ion torrent and and this uh
in this instance i am facing a lot of
problem because i i'm
i'm not good at information and don't
have that much
training for the that analysis and
that's why i'm facing a lot of problem
how to
uh analyze data and i have how i have to
visualize that data and that's why i i
i want to learn how that big data
work or uh total data analysis of
uh two related uh
sequences and um
and i have a lot of interest in
bioinformatics
because i think it's a useful tool for
the
research and because of being an uh
beginner i i search for a lot of
instructor and a lot of courses but
in this course i find something which i
can understand
actually and that's why i'm trying to
being a
part of this fellowship
thank you so much ali so concluding it
all
uh you all are here to learn more about
bioinformatics its tools
and then the various uh different sorts
of
things uh domains let's say the machine
learning data signs or infectious
diseases
so we have a lot of courses asynchronous
course material
you can go through and also a lot of
programs
which are ongoing and would be coming
soon we would be
introducing them to you all really very
soon so you can be a part of it and
learn more
and further our mentor would take you
through how you have to go through it or
yes so uh india would you like to add
something
yeah so actually that's where i wanted
to um
to go next um all of you have signed up
right and many of you have already
started this process
of uh taking the coursework and i think
that's the first
important part of starting with
just learning and it
data and you can visualize the data and
you know some basic tools for
analysis and so um the first thing that
i want to ask you
how many of you have completed your
profile
okay so what do i mean by a completed
profile
just like we did today with showing your
video
and talking a little bit about yourself
this profile
is that's what it's built to do uh
here you have you can add your profile
picture
you can add social media links and
that's important because
if you think about your career your
research
you get to develop a network of
like-minded people
and so many of us are on linkedin so
we'd love to connect with all of you on
linkedin so if you could add some of
those social media links here
and you can add a little bit information
about yourself so that we know
who you are obviously we won't be
remembering all the information that you
share
every time and the other thing is
building up your profile so building up
your profile means that you are
completing the coursework so the way
that this
process will work with mentors is
mentors are going to be looking at the
coursework that you have completed
and they will be trying to evaluate the
amount of effort that you put in
to address some of the technical
challenges that you are
facing so the mentor
or the other research fellows really
cannot do this for you
you have to do this for yourself and so
this is one place that we can go to see
how much you have done how much you have
completed
what kinds of topics have you learned
about maybe what you are interested in
and so we're going to be looking to hear
from you what you have learned
in these weekly sessions but also to see
how much progress you're making
especially if you are interested in
machine learning or
you're interested in a particular data
type like transcriptomic data
or source code too another thing that
somalia already mentioned
is that we have ongoing programs
these programs are organized to
give you a guided session
following similar types of material that
you will find asynchronously
so essentially if you go through the
coursework and then you need help
uh going through some technical issue
or maybe applying this to an example
this is the place where you should go
and you should find different programs
if you just go to the programs tab
and we do have some uh very nice
programs
that are being organized for the whole
summer so
please explore those and you can search
here for different things
and you'll find many different types of
programs
now finally
of mentorship
when we come
with an idea and you are starting to
focus on that idea and you already know
what you're going to be doing
you still can get stuck in many
different places
these could be technical things these
could be things that
are related to biology maybe that you
don't understand completely
and maybe they just come with experience
so a mentor is essentially someone
that has gone through the same
frustrations that you
are going through and has figured out a
way
and maybe somebody else helped them
maybe somebody
showed them the way and guided them
through that and now they are sharing
that experience with you
so before you come to a mentor what's
really important
is to be able to share with them as much
information as possible
about your journey and about where you
are and what exactly you're struggling
with
and that starts with our weekly form
that
uh maybe sonalika you could share the
link again here in the chat
okay and so what is the form and how to
fill it out the form is essentially a
way for
all of us before the meeting to
understand
what is it that you have done this week
and where you are in this process
and so um let me just share my screen
again i'll kind of show all of you
okay so here you will find 20 steps
and these 20 steps sorry to interact we
can
if you can stop your video sharing i
think there's a problem with uh
that and it's getting lag yeah okay
thank you so this program form has to be
filled out
before the session so before you come to
this weekly
session you have to fill this out so
that we can have
a little bit of time to review and
understand
even either that you have a specific
question
or that you are ready to present so
these sessions
today we're talking a lot but typically
in these sessions
you will get to speak a lot more and so
if you can let us know
if you have a presentation about what
you have learned
or you have a presentation about your
project proposal
or you have a presentation about a
completed project where you need
a feedback from the whole group you need
to let us know
by following these steps and essentially
uh you know doing it a little bit before
we get to the meeting so that that's an
important part here
okay so um hopefully this clarifies a
little bit
the process and the way that the program
works
i want to um ask dr
harpreet kaur who is a mentor
and really a coordinator of this whole
program
to share a little bit about her
background
and what she has done as a part of her
mentorship here in the program
and then we will pass it on to some of
the research fellows that we'll be
presenting today
thank you
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd
in bioinformatics so let me just talk
about
about why i joined bioinformatics so
after doing my masters in molecular
biology and biochemistry
i was always interested in analyzing
those molecular mechanisms that are
taking place in human disease conditions
specifically cancer
so thereafter i joined phd in
bioinformatics at csir
institute of microbial technology in
india
uh in august 2015 with professor gps
ragwa
who is one of well-known bioinformatics
scientists in india
and as well as across the globe and so
my phd research
area was cancer genomics especially the
liver cancer
so now let me give you some glimpse
about
how bioinformatics will help you to
study different
disease conditions particularly uh
liver cancer malignancy by taking some
examples from my
phd research process
so first what inspired me to study liver
cancer
is is the high mortality rate of this
malignancy
and lack of precise biomarkers that can
help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
so the another factor that contributes
its poor prognom prognosis is the
outcome of the
or the poor prognosis or outcome of
liver cancer facing
is the frequent reoccurrence of the
tumor after the treatment
so by keeping these concern in mind so i
have designed different research process
for my phd work
so first to understand what is already
done
in uh in the field of liver cancer so i
went through the previous literature and
collected information
regarding existing biomarkers to
understand
what are the major limitations and
advantages associated with
already identified liver cancer
biomarkers
so based on the collected information
related to those biomarkers
we have developed a publicly available
database which is cancer liver
which contain comprehensive information
on nearly 600 biomarkers or potential
biomarker candidate for the liver cancer
so besides to address new research
questions
i had also uniformly processed various
types of data sets
that are available on different
platforms
so thus this uh cancer level also
maintains
nearly 115 data sets of nearly
uh 10 000 liver cancer patient samples
so then in the next part we use large
scale transcriptomics data to identify
diagonal
diagnostic biomarker panel for
hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary liver malignancy
so here we employed 30 data set
containing
nearly 4 000 samples to elicit a
transcriptomic biomarker panel for the
diagnosis
and the prognosis of the liver cancer
implementing
various machine learning techniques
so thereafter we use transcriptomics as
well as methylation data to identify
biomarker panel for the stage
classification
of the hepatocellular carcinoma so for
this purpose
we use tcca data of 350 samples and
elucidate 51 features
which include 30 rna transcripts and 21
cpg
methylation sites using number of the
bioinformatics
or data mining techniques
so in the third part we focused on
another
primary labor malignancy which is
cleansio carcinoma
so here we employed nine data set
containing 350 cleanser carcinoma 130
it is a non-tumorous and 90 xcc samples
to scrutinize clencho carcinomas pacific
transcriptomic
signatures using various machine
learning techniques
overall during my phd
i have scrutinized three hcc biomarker
that can discriminate scc and the normal
samples
then in the subsequent project we have
identified ccs pacific signature
to identify chlangiocarcinoma from axis
in the normals and
normal sample so in the subsequent part
we have also tried to identify
important signatures that can predict
fcc at
early stage
so besides i got also opportunity to
mentor
i'm texturing during my uh doctoral
period time
so here i uh i was i uh i was co-mentor
for four students out of which one
research article is already published
and one is still in communication
and two are under manuscript preparation
so then thereafter when i joined fine
biotech
in my current role i am curriculum
developer and research consultant
uh here as well i got the opportunity to
go mentor number of research follows
in omics logic research fellowship
program which is this current program
so now let me give you a glimpse of some
of the project that was completed by
our research fellows where i mentored
so one of our research fellow who uh
miss
sime uh semai dolan uh an undergraduate
student from turkey
uh have completed her research project
entitled long down coding
rnas as therapeutic target in chronic
lymphocytic
leukemia using publicly available data
and
various bioinformatics tools that are
integrated on tbinfo server
then we have ms ucha parikh who is
postgraduate student from india
completed her research projects
on identification of the biomarker to
differentiate between neural stem cell
and glioblastoma stem cells
employing publicly available data from
the glioblastoma
and various tools on t banford server
next mr kalaumari who is a phd student
uh in mexico has completed his research
project
on classification of triple negative
breast cancer cell lines
by gene expression analysis of
transmembrane protein using machine
learning algorithms
then apart from the oncology field then
we have the ms de lara
de queen who is a master student from
turkey has completed
metagenomics project on space radiation
street
effect so apart from the graduate or
master student
i have also got the opportunity to
mentor high school students
from different part of the globe
so here we have nitra siri sidney
varshan who is a high school student in
the usa
so completed her research project on
effect of the onset
onset of menopause on the
transcriptomics profile of the easing
female brain
and she's already presented her poster
at
international conference then we have
mr andres who is also a high school
student
at mexico city he is also able to
complete his project
on alzheimer
so my research interest lies in the
application of bioinformatics in
different human health aspects
but my primary research interest is of
course oncology
or cancer genomics besides this oncology
i'm also
currently doing research in different
areas like infectious disease
neuroscience etc
so based on my research experience let's
talk about what should be
approach to design or research project
so what are the major steps that are
important
whenever you designing any research
project
so first first of all you must frame
your research
problem then go through the literature
review to understand what is already
done in that particular area
and try to find out what are the
important research questions
that still needs to be addressed or what
are uh
drawbacks if some of the questions were
already addressed
then collected raw data that i
that is needed to address your research
questions so next step is
pre-processing of those data sets
for downstream analysis so once you have
processed data
next is you must go for exploratory data
analysis to understand
what are important patterns in your data
so then you must perform in-depth
analysis
to address your different research
queries
finally when you have completed all the
research questions
so then uh you can compile those results
or summarize those results in in the
form of research report publication
or maybe uh in the form of presentation
for the conference
so thank you everyone i'm looking
forward
being your mentor in this program so if
you have any question please go ahead
and i will uh answer your question
thank you so much dr harpreet for
letting us know about
you your research background and what
your research area
is i hope uh that helped out of the
research fellows
uh know about what the specialization of
dr harpreet is and how they can get
benefited from it now moving ahead
i would want uh drew our research fellow
to please present his research progress
over to youtube oh hello everyone
i hope i am audible yes you are audible
okay i shared my screen
you can see yourself thank you
okay so today i'm here to present my
uh the progress of my research project
called transcriptomic analysis of
esophageal carcinoma and a quick
introduction uh my name is romero i'm a
graduate in medical biotechnology
so i've done my undergraduation from
amity university noida
in india so at present i'm working as a
research fellow at find biotech
and talk about my past experiences i
worked as an intern
in research and sangha department of a
precision medicine company
so there i along with my team used to
work on genomics
and ngs technologies and other than that
i
worked on worked as an easter pathology
intern in a government hospital
here in the lead cell so talking about
my research interest i'm interested in
precision medicine
cancer biology genomics and
transcriptomics
and through this fellowship i'm actually
uh you know
expanding my horizons in the field of
data science
so just uh uh i'll brief about the topic
so ace of three this is actually a
muscular organ that connects your
pharynx to the stomach
and esophageal carcinoma is actually a
malignant neoplasis
that is associated with tobacco use
alcohol consumption
and efficiency of vitamin a b3 and c
so this condition is actually associated
with the esophagitis
celiac disease and good
so talking about the epidemiology uh
these figures are from the who
uh cancer repository so these figures
are from year 2020
there were more than six hundred
thousand cases of uh esophageal
carcinoma
and more than 540 000 death
uh due to the same and talking about the
geographical distribution uh asian
population
actually reported the highest number of
esophageal carcinomas
and these figures are quite surprising
uh as
as it indicates uh you know the need for
uh new and
new therapeutic prognostic and
diagnostic approaches
to treat this cancer and that was the
major
you know motivation for me to pursue
this project
so before defining my hypothesis i just
describe my data set so for this study
i've actually
used the pcga data so which was labeled
as esophageal carcinoma
and it consists of 980 samples so there
are 13 normal samples
and 185 tumor samples
so talking about my hypothesis uh by
this
research project i want to attain two
major objectives
first is to know more about the gene
signatures involved in cancer
progression
and second is to look for biomarkers or
gene signatures associated with the
prognosis of the disease so
here is a analysis plan which i
have followed till now so i started with
data preparation
so i actually make match the metadata
with the expression data
and along with that i took the average
of the
duplicate genes and then i started with
the exploratory analysis
i did the pca and today i will be
sharing the results of these pca
so uh here is the first pca so i was
actually uh you know uh
working towards the first hypothesis and
uh to my surprise i found this uh
interesting
uh interesting clusters so in this pc
there are actually uh you know
two clusters uh which which have been
formed so first on your right and
the second on your left so after uh
talking with my mentor i actually
looked into into the metadata for
understanding this
these two clusters
so it turned out to be uh these two
clusters are actually
uh you know the sub type of this
esophageal carcinoma
so uh before moving i i will just
quickly describe these two uh subtypes
so esophageal carcinoma is actually
divided into uh two subtypes
first is your esophageal sphamma
cerebral carcinoma and second is the
esophageal adenocarcinoma
so talking about the esophageal spammer
cell carcinoma it's a
malignant epithelial tumor with scar
cell differentiation
it's it's found in the epithelium which
is the innermost
lining of these phages and it is most
common in the middle third of these
surfaces
and it is associated with risk factors
such as tobacco use
uh alcohol abuse and micronutrient
deficiency
as i told earlier the deficiency of
vitamin a v3 and c
so talking about the esophageal
adenocarcinoma it's
actually a malignant tumor of the
esophagus with
glandular tissue involvement so uh
this type this uh cancer subtype is
actually
localized to the distal receptors uh
towards the
lower uh towards the stomach side i
would say
and there are quite a risk factors
associated with it
uh such as the barricade surface so
and the good so barracks esophagus is
actually a
pre-neoplastic condition uh in which the
squamous cells are actually converted
into the
columnar uh intense type of cells
and a gird is a gastroesophageal reflux
of acid
so uh here is a stepwise uh like this
figure describes the carcinogenesis so
has a
normal uh esophageal epithelium and
uh first we will talk about the superior
strongest cell carcinoma
so there is uh ins continuous insult
from alcohol tobacco and thermal injury
uh which leads to subsequent stages of
carcinogenesis
uh such as spammers hypoplasia squamous
dysplasia and then to the full-blown
neoplasm which is called as the
esophageal stomach cell carcinoma
and in the second subtype there is
formation of the
barrett esophagus which is due to the
acid reflux and the
bile reflux which leads to transversion
uh subsequently leading to the displaced
dysplastic
barracks esophagus and then to a full
blown uh
esophageal adenocarcinoma and there is
uh one surprising finding which uh which
i found surprising
uh during like during the course of
learning about these two subtypes
so talking about the geographical
distribution of these two
uh cancers cancer subtype so
uh in the figure a uh it it actually
describes the incidence of the
esophageal adenocarcinoma so it is
clearly evident all the
developed nations have reported
like majorly reported the uh
esophageal adenocarcinoma while
while to my surprise it was totally
different for us farmer cell esophagus
from a cell carcinoma
so all the developing nations uh as it
is evident
reported uh majorly reported the ace
officials from mississippi
so going back to my pc again so
after understanding these two clusters
which were the subtypes i
individually plotted the pca so here is
the
pc of a normal tissue along with the uh
isophageal adenocarcinoma so it is
clearly evident that
there are again two clear clusters uh
with outliers
and then i repeated this with the
another subtype
so here is the normal and the esophageal
stem muscle carcinoma
so again there are two uh clear cut
clusters
along with the along with two outliers
so for my for extending my research
project i
i'm actually uh looking for probably
uh i'll be doing a comparative analysis
between the two subtypes
so i'm thinking of actually you know
finding a probable uh therapeutic target
which is
common to both the subtypes which which
can actually
uh you know help in better management of
the cancers
uh and again i want to work on uh better
ways to stratify
patients based on the subtypes so
thank you this was pretty much about my
presentation
hello yeah very nice presentation thank
you
very detailed and i think that you know
you can clearly see
uh the process of how exploration of
data and understanding the different
phenotypes really helps you
identify i think very interesting
questions
um so maybe we can open it to everyone
does anyone have any
questions or comments on drew's
presentation
okay through i uh i just want to ask
because i
ask you one another thing when we are
doing this part okay so have you look
into the literature like
uh whether there is already uh
transcriptomic signatures
available or maybe or tr or any maybe
the protein signature
may be transcriptomic signature that
classify these two subtypes
uh mom i have been looking for that and
till now uh
i haven't got these specific papers but
i'm actually
looking at the individual subtypes so
like there are
molecular signatures associated with uh
simply the
ace of phases yeah you will find them
actually easily as much as my knowledge
you will find that very easy
but i am more interested in these
subtypes like
uh because uh whenever we actually
develop some signature we always uh
interested
if for example a particular uh
malignancy arise from
same tissue right it's like same thing
all those cells are different
so it's like whether you can actually
classify
those two subtypes based on
transcriptomics data
because that is what important question
looks to me i mean at this point of time
so it because i have also tried to find
out just
from the overview so i am not getting
the publication but yeah i have not
uh i mean uh did thorough literature
review that is why
i have asked you to do that uh yes ma'am
i'm actually working on that and uh
till now i haven't found a single paper
which is combining these two substrates
but again i'll look into the dip and
then we can actually work on that
maybe you just need to look at once the
original tcga paper that is associated
with this data
so on gdc data portal you can easily
find out all on tcg itself
just if you search these keywords tcga
data
and this uh esophageal cancer so you can
easily maybe i mean i just want to look
at
just look at that publication exactly
whether they have tried to do something
with these two subtypes because the data
that we are taking
that is from the tcga directly ah yes
so i'll look into it and then uh i'll
tell you about it okay so if any uh
anyone else have any question please go
ahead
can i just uh share a very quick
comment yes please you can
yeah it seems it seems that you can
kind of isolate each of these samples
that are
clustered in the green side and also the
samples that are in the red
side uh i don't know which exactly which
is
which i don't know exactly which program
you use to plot this but
uh if you use a tool called dc2 you can
go to these tumors and then perform a
differential expression analysis and get
to know which genes are
upregulated in the red tumors and which
genes are
for instance downregulated in the
in the green tumors and then that those
are going to be
kind of signatures that you would know
are associated with each of these
tumor types basically okay so i
work on the differentially expressed
genes so i'll be comparing
these two groups and then i have also
asked you to subtitles i mean for the
day sect
you must apply between two subtypes
cancer versus normal is fine
but if you remember i have asked you to
also perform d sec
on these two subtypes as uh even uh
uh so i think already
uh we also talk about this thing so i
think you must consider these same yeah
okay i'll definitely consider these
three points and then i'll present in
the next
thank you so much drew uh opinion can we
have
you next piece
hello my opinion yes
okay let me share my my ppt please thank
you
hello everyone uh hope i'm audible
yes peniel you are audible
oh
oh this place might not be a good
convenient for for the video it looks
great it looks great
it looks great we can see you smiling so
that's good
all right all right all right oh okay so
my name is pineal um
presently in china but i am a tanzanian
by
nationality i'm actually here for my phd
studies
and my background is in clinical
but i did masters in anatomy and
molecular neurobiology
and at the moment i'm doing a phd in
neuroscience
this is uh this
study is about parkinson's disease what
i deal with
in in in in my phds is actually
uh a single cell sequencing uh of study
in in in neurogenic disease particularly
in parkinson's disease
and uh just for the sake of this uh
uh so i've come up
with a topic in in parkinson's disease
and and
it's about uh levodopa which is the drug
for treatment of parkinson's disease but
it has a side effect
which is dyskinesia therefore
the topic is the nova biometers for
level over induced dyskinesia in
in in parkinson's disease potential
target for anti-dyskinetic therapy
development
just a minute okay so uh
pd is actually the second common
neurogenic disease which affects two to
three
old population and perhaps they might
increase in
in the future and just in the nutshell
it is it is it is
characterized by some features which are
which are very common in clinics
rigidity
tremors bradykinesia which is
slow in movement and this was actually
first developed i mean
this was from uh james parkinson
which is a is a scientist as a doctor
actually
who came up with this uh
disease and uh he
it is called parkinson's disease because
of uh
pac james parkinson's james parkinson
so what is actually happening in the
brain is a loss
of dopamine neurons in some nuclear
in the brain that produce
uh dopamine and uh there is
uh several uk but most common and uh
in in the in the brain is fewer men
coverage nucleus and subthalamic
nucleus globus pallidus and substantia
[ __ ] mainly substantial
negra and these two other nuclei
so what is happening is actually the
degeneration
of dopamine euros in this uh
nuclei now it is important for me to
talk about this one because
uh this project is is mainly in a
pathway there are two pathways over here
which is direct and indirect pathway
there is a pathway connected from
substantia [ __ ] to uh
to the putamen putamen and caudas
nucleus
from this point to this point and then
there's another pathway connected from
and put them into this point globus
pallidus
so this is called cow that
pallida cauted uh crowded putamen and
pallidus
and these are the pathway which is
direct pathways carbon nucleus
uh to and subcoded pyramid and
substantia
so uh uh
at the moment there is uh actually in
the provision of integrated treatment
for pd
uh a patient with this disorder the
discovery of the government is a
neurotransmitter in the brain
its deficiency in any parkinson's
disease patients
and replacement with developer therapy
has been
major revolutionary events
now what is happening is that
despite the contemporary effect of
leptopa and
uh in production of neurons
it loses efficacy over time and with
accompanying side effects which is
this is dyskinesia
[Music]
so it has been reported that this
kinesia is the main
um drawback actually for for
for the treatment for treatment for
level of treatment
and many many
people have documented and have reported
it already
and you can see in this uh just some of
the publications
and therefore the development of new
therapy for interventions
to mitigate this uh the risk of
dyskinesia and parkinson's disease
it does a high priority no one cannot do
that without
knowing the molecular signatures that
are actually
causing that dyskinesia in the brain
now to uncover this we have performed
bioinformatics on micro data set and
from a geo and identify the differential
it expressed genes using lima package
and then later we we we performed the
geo and egg enrichment
and uh probably employing a protein
protein interaction as well
we we checked on that now
just for sake of this uh
uh presentation the the metadata has
44 samples
in direct pathway and it has 33
samples in indirect pathway these are
models this uh it is the animal model
and for this case was
mice so there were 44 for this uh
mode of direct pathway and 33 for this
one
but uh for direct pathway this again
we are subclassed into parkinson's
disease model this is one of the
toxins we use for pakistan disease model
and
a control group and then the parkinson's
disease model where father divided
chronic high level upper treatment
chronic low leveled upper treatment and
and the control group was treated with
chronic saline
similarly to the indirect pathway these
uh were further divided into parkinson's
disease and control group and were 33
23 and 10 and the pd model
further divided into eight for chronic
high level
eight for chronological and seven for
the control group was today with chronic
saline
so oops
so the results is uh the first thing
that we
want to report is that the chronic high
level dopamine is
chronic low level low dose phenomena
of levodopa treatment reveals no
significant molecular changes on
indirect pathway but rather on direct
pathway
now how do we perform this is we check
on the chronic
high versus chronic low level of our
treatment first in indirect pathway and
later we check
on the direct pathway so in in direct
pathway actually there is no clear
demarcation and cleared and mean
different or separation between
these two the chronicle and chronic high
level treatment and we if we checked
further and we saw
the prone i mean the volcano plot
and and the main difference plot which
shows
actually very few genes which were
up regulated and perhaps might even be
um uh my
my my path might be even more
significant
but we actually checked on that genes
and we only found
a single three which was
uh uh which was actually significant
just a single
and it was high in chronic high levodopa
and it was high in chronic low level and
high in
chronic and low in chronic high level
but these genes actually
it's a protein-coding genes and today
yeah the two of us
there are diseases
and this is related to uh
ligase activity and uh ambiguity in
pro-intro and transference activity and
and button about for ubr2
now we we checked on this repository
it's called platform uh of open target
uh see what is if this is
really related to parkinson's disease
and we
found that we checked and uh this one
shows the number of association genetic
association if that gene is really
uh uh expressed in the cng for example
it's this there are
number of uh variables here which this
gains expressed in
highly expressing platelet counts
particularly counts
but again we checked it down and we
found it that it also expressed in
parkinson's disease
due to a parkinson's disease due to
atp1382 deficiency
if we check on globally you will find
that this gene actually
has several associations
neurodegenerative disease
but uh it has been reported that 30 to
90
78 percent has been reported in in in
parkinson's disease
due to atp 1382 deficiency
so we we again checked on the direct
pathway
remember we are only talking about the
dosage high dose and low dose
and a chronic high end chronic uh
chronic high and chronic law
and for that we found that i was a clear
demarcation
uh between the chronic high level and
chronic
lower level over and this was the uh
umap humor plot
and we found uh thousands of genes which
were downregulated and
upregulated according to p adjusted p
value of less than 0.05 but what is
interesting is that we had to
um we have to choose the up and down
regulator according to
the values which recommended and this is
p adjusted of course of less than 0.0
0.05 and log to fall change
of more than 1.5 and for this case we
found
only 22 genes were upregulated
and one gene was down regulated
so in this is heat map in heat map we
found
uh uh several i mean those 22 genes
these are blossoming fridges
of upregulated and we have a number of
genes here one thing is
one thing interesting that we have here
which we have been dealing with for some
uh for two or three years now in our lab
and this is a gene which is very
important for the
development maturation of dopamine
neurons
and what is interesting that is in
dyskinesia
it is hyper expressed
this gene you can even use for treatment
of
disease in fact over over expression in
fact
parkinson's disease patients have low
expression of this disease i mean this
gene
that we can again be used for treatment
of
pd by over expression but one thing is
which is surprising is that it is also
hyper expressed in in in
dyskinesia oh this is
this is the heat map of chronic high
level ropa and chronic
uh high level robot so we checked
what what is on geo uh geo as what is
the function molecular function
biological function of the business
and we found that most of these uh
these upregular genes were involved in
blending
and uh and then in biological process
most of these genes were involved in
biological regulation and cellular
process
and process but again in cellular
component it was
we found that it is involved these 22
genes are involved in cellular
anatomical
entity cellular anatomical entity
the pathway we found that these
genes have regulated genes they are
involved mostly
in tgf better signaling pathway
so now what are those novel biomarkers
this kind of matter of fact as a matter
of fact
if we get this uh biomarkers of
level up and use this kind of they can
be used for treatment of this dispenser
by
using uh inhibitors because if they are
hyper
hyperregulated or hyper expressed you
can use inhibitors
to regulate bring them down uh
uh when it when they are high by
expressing this dyskinesia
so what we did is that we again in the
direct pathway we
checked on the uh now three uh chronic
high level europa chronic low leveropa
and chronic saline
which was the control group and we found
that there was a clear demarcation
between the first
the chronic chronic this is the control
group and this uh chronic high and
chronic
means that there are something which is
happening
between this level of a treatment and
the control group
when i see okay now we we found
thousands of genes which were actually
participating is both parameters
and uh 1049s but these genes will help
them down into significant genes
uh of course this where this was the uh
volcano of
those three uh conditions i mean uh
treatment
flow of vessel scrolling styling chronic
hive is growing
low level this
vessel scoring saline and we
we narrowed those genes down
into this again i mean by using the log
two-fold change of more than 1.5
and we found that 438
were actually up regulated here 2000
i mean 236 and 22 genes were uh
just 99 and 2028
were down downregulated india
respectively
so uh we use the veni diagram
and uh hello hi penis
hi opinion i'm so sorry to interrupt you
in between but i
think we are running out of time and uh
we would have to take your next
slide in the next meeting can we do that
oh that's okay that's okay yes yes thank
you so much for sharing your progress
and seeing that you have worked a lot on
your research and your progress is
amazing
and uh i'm really sorry i had to do
that maybe india just need to add
comments yeah
yeah just let me add uh one quick
comment uh pineapple
i think that um you know you
you've definitely done a lot of the
analysis as you're thinking of
completing your project the
bioinformatics part i know that you also
want to do validation
but for the bioinformatics part for the
review sessions
it's fine that we hear all of the steps
that you did
and all the different types of analyses
that you've performed
but ultimately to tell us the full story
and for us not to get lost in the
details i think you need to select
the most impactful figures
and uh show us essentially
what is the most meaningful and clear
result that you're getting
and you know that will also probably
help you in writing your paper or you
know if you're going to do a poster
presentation at some point
because you know you do have to make
those hard choices you know what do you
tell about what do you not tell about
am i supposed to respond uh at the
moment or
i mean yeah this is just as much i don't
know if anyone else wants to add
something to that harpreet
or anyone else i think that you know
this is kind of like a common
uh common issue that comes up
i think nice presentation only if you
just make it small i mean
just include important results or like
this uh
research scholarship yes for one on one
meeting you can present everything
because
sometimes we need to look at what are
exactly done but yeah for this meeting
probably you just uh
can make it short yeah
yeah thank you so much helia and dr
halperi thank you so much
uh and
we'll get back to your research work
maybe in the next meeting or we can have
a one-on-one session as well
you seem to get saddened upon
about the opinion you need not uh feel
bad about it it's just that
we have a lot a lot of research fellows
to
talk to and see their progress
and uh for us to cover all of that in a
limited time
frame is a challenge that's why i had to
intro
okay so uh dr harpreet uh
do we have uh some uh we had rajneesh
as well to present i think but we can
ask them uh
for maybe session meeting or instead of
yes ma'am
yes ma'am so rajneesh uh we'll take your
presentation in your
badge meeting and uh for today's meeting
i would like to end it here
and if anyone else wants to add a
comment they can
yeah hello everyone i do have something
to add
yes please
so it was great to see the mentors
presenting today
and really loved the way uh some of the
presentation went
about so especially
uh deepo liano if i'm
pronouncing your name correctly you can
correct correct
you may call me geo if it's easier yeah
jio okay that that's great
okay so yeah that i mean it was nice
so really like that so for today uh to
end this i mean conclude this i mean
what we were trying to say
and one of the things that i wanted to
address before
we all started but it missed the chance
and opportunity about that
that uh many of the bioinformatics
analysis and many students that i've
interacted with they
they kind of think bioinformatics to be
a separate domain
from uh other scientific uh
areas of research like they separated
from um
from plant biology or from agriculture
and from maybe cancer they don't think
about
like how bioinformatics is now changed
and is
is now been applied to all of these
research areas so
here is an opportunity to work on any of
the areas that you
love to work on you have been working on
maybe hearing
things about some of the specific
interests that
that has developed over time and we
don't know about it so
different ideas from different research
interns here is one of the objectives to
go about
and to like you know uh so that we can
help you out with that
and uh second thing that i wanted to say
is that
uh we would be looking forward for your
progress
through your profile so we'll be always
looking out there
one thing uh there i wanted to add is
that
many times what many times what happens
is that many of our collaborators
are also like our running companies
our universities and all of that so they
reach out to us and they ask us
if if you have some interesting students
who would want to work with us uh either
as an intern or a full-time
participant or uh or like a job
opportunity
so in that case we kind of share
profiles
so the uh so the educational profile on
the
learn platform is very important there
it makes sense because uh there you can
see someone's progress and like
uh get an overview of from the from the
links and all
we will also be sharing a detailed
profile uh
document where you can tell a little bit
more about yourself
that we can also like you that we can uh
we'll be using to share with
uh the recruiter based on their interest
so those are some of the opportunities
that i wanted to
uh tell you about and other than that
other than that there is a really
interesting session
that is upcoming so it's on space
uh astrobiology's so it's an
astrobiology session
uh which would be on which would be on
uh 17 june so you you all are invited so
it's a cyomic session and many of you
are already part of the
club so we'd love to invite you for this
session
in this session there will be uh there
will be
uh um presentations by the lara you
already have heard about the lara's
project right of her breathe and there
will be a presentation by ruth we
that is something about literature
review so many of you might have been
like you know
starting your project and would require
to go through the literature review part
and it's very important and like uh
plays in
really tremendous role in all of this
bioinformatics analysis that we are
trying to do
so uh this will be also covered in the
session and then we have our
uh research fellow from 2019 subrajit
purua
and he has been uh working with several
organizations he has a keen interest in
astrobiology
and is now also uh working with other
an organization called space nova and
also have done uh analysis
with us on research fellowship on liver
cancer project
so he'll be talking about his research
experience and career suggestions
on astrobiology so we'll be looking
forward for to you
for all of you to maybe join these
sessions and reach out to us with all of
the questions that you have had
uh for the next step of analysis that
might be also from the learn platform
that you're going through you're
completing some of the coursework some
of the data types that you're interested
in
you can complete genomics you can
compute transcriptomics epigenomics
machine learning
all of those uh research technologies
are available to you so it depends on
your interest if you have those kind of
uh applications we'll be really
happy to help you with you know
integrating data as well so
that that is what i wanted to add for
today's meeting it was nice to
see you all and uh me to meet with you
all who are
who have joined for the first time and
we look forward for interacting
with you throughout the week so please
feel free to
uh you know ping us on the slack channel
so we see there is a less activity on
the slack channel so we are expecting
you to
be more interactive on there because
it's really easy you can put it on your
phone and just like
you know typing messages you can put
your questions out there you will
find the links and you can you know it's
it's kind of simple
yeah that's uh what i wanted to say and
now
i'll just pass it on to
sunalika to end the session thank you
thank you so much dr mohit for sharing
all the information and thank you so
much
everyone for being a part of today's
meeting
and we are looking forward to your
participation tomorrow as
dr mohit told we have the psionic
session that is on astrobiology
and we would be looking we would be
looking ahead for your participation
there as well
and uh those who were new in today's
meeting
we could not uh take them through with
the next steps they have to go ahead
with
so uh i would be scheduling a meeting
with the
new parties defense
to take them through what all programs
and what all courses they have to
uh go ahead with so you would be
required to
take the asynchronous course material
course material
and also the sample projects first and
then you would start with working on
your research project
so dr harpreet and dr mohit would be
guiding you throughout uh the process
i would be linked with the details
soon and then we can go ahead with your
fellowship program ahead and if you have
any doubts you
you can anytime mail me at marketing at
the rate pine dot by one i'll be there
to help you out
with any of the problems you face and
also those who have joined the research
fellowship meeting i've already given
you the access to all the content on the
omixlogic learn portal
so you can just go on the portal and
explore the courses and project samples
we have
and yes you can start with it based on
your research interest and then we have
the meeting we'll share how we go
further about it
uh let me jump in here um ali are you
still on
oh no problem um i wanted to mention uh
you know you were talking about
sequencing solar scope 2
um harpreet first of all could be a
great
help in you know showing you some
examples
of visualization and analysis that you
can start with but also we have an
online course
so maybe you could complete that course
and let us know so we can discuss
specifically what you're trying to do
okay i'll do okay
and um i also wanted to ask
uh adekunle and uh hamza i think maybe
it's still here
are you still here yes i'm here
okay so um uh i don't know if it
makes sense uh to uh connect
with others here that are from nigeria
uh and separately trying to coordinate a
session for the nigerian participants
to see if there's some overlap in
interest
hamza has left but i
did want to mention that we have an
ongoing project
on malaria covid uh
cytokine storm and immunity
so maybe this is something that we think
about there
and we wanted to invite a group of
students
from ghana that are working on
malaria-related projects so maybe we
could invite them
and the people here that are from
nigeria to have
one african group and discuss all the
you know hear those presentations uh
understand what they have done
hear about the interests of your group
uh something like that
it's okay that would be fine it would be
good to to connect with the
the ghanaian team and see what they've
done and i'm
pretty sure that we equally guide them i
mean some of the
new researchers research fellows that
are joining this
program in terms of being able to
formulate their
their their projects or readily join
existing projects so as to continue with
that so i
will look forward to that um that
session if it can happen please
okay so everyone here that is from
nigeria or
africa i put in africa at pine bio
that's the email address for adekunle
and his team so maybe you could connect
with them
and just coordinate a time typically
with a group from ghana we meet on
fridays
but you know depending on what works
with you we can uh
discuss after the meeting it's okay i
will try and coordinate with the team
here and then see when we can
do that okay
great maybe you could share your details
with those that are here just so that
they know how to reach you
okay so yes you can reach me via africa
pine i would like to leave my personal
email also to
to guide maybe a direct interaction
or perhaps phone number if that would be
okay too for whatsapp connection
so i would drop that in the chat box
uh and also you can just put that in the
slack channel actually because we're
gonna
leave the meeting now and i don't know
if everybody's gonna have a chance to
uh okay
all right great thank you i'm great to
meet everybody who's new
thank you very much thank you
you so much india thanks thank you so
much everyone uh
we meet soon bye take care